I guess DC when I'm broken head.
No,
no,
no.
He beat somebody in a very impressive fight.
Oh,
it was Roy who's big country.
Oh yeah.
I took it down.
He kept,
he kept taking down.
Yeah.
That was it.
That was a long,
the shit out of Roy could beat the shit out of Roy and it was a long fight.
Right?
Wasn't it like a five rounds?
Uh,
I don't know if it's five.
It was three rounds of an ass whooping though.
See if you find that is a monster.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He's a bad mother to help him.
And frankly the most cerebral,
I think.
Thank you.
Got clipped with a punch before.
Main advantage.
Oh Wow.
I'm impressed.
He does look very fit.
Who?
So he must've been heavy when he started camp.
Since world,
he's really heavy.
That's what it,
he didn't fight for a little bit.
So you know,
he's been commentating and find a Russian ship.
Interesting.
Here.
Here we go.
This is only three rounds.
They don't do five round main event.
So only title fights.
Here we go.
Can you,
what do you think about that?
I kind of agree with that.
Yeah.
I'm not mad at it.
I like five rounds.
Three rounds.
It goes too quick.
I like five rounds for smaller weight classes.
So good point.
My,
my thing would be,
man,
the five round fights are beatings,
man.
I mean,
you really,
oh,
it's over.
Oh,
it's over here.
Clipped him clover.
Oh,
trouble.
he's surviving now.
Whoa.
Take down.
He did frank.
He didn't have the under hook right there again.
That's why frank stood up.
Oh,
barges.
Throw.
Oh holy.
Oh,
I was gonna be a quick one.
I thought I was going to be a decision.
Yes.
This is phenomenal.
If it's on finch.
Oh.
Oh Shit.
It's over.
That's it.
Oh Dang.
What a war.
Dance.
Woo.
Oh Wow.
You ready for this fade or chill?
Sewn in snacks.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's really fun.
That's fucking code stacking to happen.
Wow.
Frank Mirrors.
You know,
and he almost had him,
almost had him.
It was a great throat.
That is a great fuck fucking hip toss,
Huh?
That was beautiful.
Autumn.
Some time dude fade or chail sewn in.
Wow.
When was the last time fade or one melody Denato but he really lost and Russia
lost.
Yeah,
he got hurt.
Not Fun.
Yeah,
that was crazy flat.
I forgot about that one.
Yeah,
let's,
I agree one that he wanted,
but he lost it.
So let's,
let's take those in Russia,
right?
Yes.
Let's take that one out of the equation.
He she damn,
that's right.
So Toshi was his last fight.
His retirement fight in his last run and then decided to come back after that.
I'll do this
please.
All wild and loose.
Huh?
Boom.
Wait,
the left both hands down.
Damn.
What cloud?
Just must be oh,
right there.
The left hand.
Right on the chin.
Oh boom.
Boom.
Crazy hard.
Just swinging.
They're swinging wild.
Just going.
Oh Shit.
I feel like he caught them earlier than that too,
but just that was the,
that was the big one.
The one that really hurt him.
Perfect stoppage.
God Damn,
there it is.
Oh,
it was the left.
Perfect left hand.
That was nice.
It was crazy.
This is fate or his first win in take out the Maldonado fight.
She's how many years then?
How many years?
It's been a rough go for my man.
When was he?
She,
he felt beat seeing GI deep,
all that chocolate.
That was shit.
Fight my brain.
My brain goes,
no,
that was when 15 new year's eve.
2015 you also be Pedro his though on January 21st,
2012 that was 2012 that was after the issue was 2012 oh yeah,
the,
the Pedro,
his Oh,
fight was a crazy knockout man.